hey what is up guys my name I just
imagined like like a horror movie so I'm
thinking off on someone and then being
like like hey what's up guys on it like
it's just silent and it's out of nowhere
hey sup guys my name is Jonah we're out
here got out of town once again it's
going to be a bit of a different video
we're going to be talking about how you
can get started making game alright so
games how how do people get started
making games how do I get started making
games it's probably a bit of a different
question I might say for a different
video but ultimately I get this question
a lot how does someone who's never had
any kind of programming experience any
kind of game experience how where you
begin now there's just there's there's
so many like there's so many answers to
this question that it's difficult for me
to kind of you know attempt to give the
best one or the right one because
everyone's going to be different you're
going to probably like different things
there are probably different areas of
making games that you're all interested
in so it's kind of difficult for me to
to say like exactly what you should be
doing and what you should do in order to
kind of get started with with games
because games are games and massively
complicated projects that are worked on
by like hundreds of people at times
right not necessarily but a lot of the
big ones that people in the beginning
people in the beginning always like to
kind of aim big and make really big
games really complicated games and the
fact of the matter is those games those
games that you liked it a huge right
they're going to have hundreds of people
probably working on them and if you're
just by yourself or if you've got a
small team maybe you've got a few
friends and you just wanna start making
games with them like you probably not
going to have the resources to be able
to do something like that
like on a scale so
really you should be starting with kind
of small games and stuff like that so
it's kind of the first thing that I want
you to get into your head right you need
to be able to start small you need to
kind of you might not even like making
games right like you I mean honestly I
thought I thought I loved making games
but then I just realized that actually I
was more or less interested in the
technology behind games and that's why I
currently work as as an engineer on a
game engine team because I love game
engines I love the technology behind
games the games don't interest me as
much so you definitely want to kind of
just dip your foot in the water and find
something that isn't too complicated
something small that you can kind of
start off with to see if you if you even
like making games because honestly you
might just get bored of it it's not it's
not actually it's not necessarily
something you want to invest a lot of
time in if you if you find out it's just
not for you alright so anyway that's
kind of out of the way the same is and
all that kind of stuff about about
starting about starting small but where
do you start right so I'm a game engine
programmer right I work at AAA and I
develop the core technology I develop
the game engine right so take this from
me right I love starting from scratch I
love writing all of the code that goes
into the game I love creating the game
engine myself
however the advice I'm going to give you
is don't do that
use an existing game engine and that's
kind of difficult advice to give because
again it's just so quite like I wouldn't
personally follow this advice the last
I'm giving you right now it's probably
not advice I would follow but that's
because I don't like making games that
much I like making engines so of course
I don't want to use a game engine to
make a game what purpose does that serve
right I would love to just kind of make
an engine instead but if your purpose if
your drive is to actually make a game
and finish a game and maybe even ship a
game then you you have to use an
existing game engine it's for someone
with like no programming experience for
someone with no experience in game
engine architecture or any of like you
know graphics api's and stuff like that
for you to begin with making a game
engine it's going to take you years and
you're probably going to drop it because
you'll be like I'm seeing like it took
me like three months to get a triangle
rendering right like it's just not it's
just not feasible in the future you
might decide actual
you know I've had a lot of experiencing
again I know how games are made I can
kind of move on to maybe starting to
integrate my technology using my
technology to make games however in the
beginning it's going to be critical for
you to see results right you want to be
able to develop a game and actually see
results if you don't see those results
it's not nothing's going to really
motivate you as much right as actually
seeing hey look I worked for a week and
I have this now I have this to show for
it whereas a lot of like game engine
design especially in the beginning I
know this because I started that way
right a lot of that kind of game engine
design in the beginning it's more or
less going to be you working for weeks
and not really seeing anything or seeing
something that you could have done in
two seconds of Suns coming up doing
something that you could have done in
two seconds using a game engine you know
what I love going out here and filming
because like check this out it is
absolutely gorgeous out here look at
that sunset look at that I'm literally
that is what is literally that is what
is in front of me right now alright
anyway back to it so pre-made game
engines right the big the two big
choices that you've kind of got are
really unity and unreal
and those two engines are both extremely
capable they're both they're both
engines that I would like trust right to
produce make game what I mean by that is
when you put a lot of work into a game
and maybe you've got people working for
you may be good got friends and you're
making a game you want you want to use
proven technology right so that you
don't end up having to redo a lot of
work and so unity and unreal I'm gonna
duck here behind the Sun real quick and
so unity and unreal are kind of true
technologies that have been around for
such a long time that they are stable
right now I could go into my opinion of
the two engines they're really the only
thing I would say is is use one that
maybe people around you are more
familiar with use one that maybe you're
more likely to have experience with you
might have already done something for
school or university in unity for
example so you use unity right it
doesn't matter it's a tool right unless
you're going to start making a very very
specific game or some kind of triple a
production like I would not recommend
unity or unreal for kind of Triple A
games maybe unreal is kind of feasible
but unity definitely not nobody's unity
interpolate games pretty much
because it's just it's not like there
are a lot of problems with anyway the
idea is pick an engine that you like
pick an engine that you think that you
think you might run into people that use
because having people to support you
having people through actually help you
out with using the tools is going to be
something that's really important
especially in the early kind of
especially in in the early kind of hours
I could say of your actual like of your
actual experience because the most
important thing I would say in the
beginning is just finding something that
motivates you if you lose motivation
it's going to be really tough for you to
just be on the grind and keep learning
because making games as I said is tough
making games is not something that is
easy no matter if you're using unity or
if you're on it if you're rocking your
own engine it doesn't matter right
like making games is hard and if you're
just getting started with it you need
something to keep motivating you right
you need to stay motivated you need to
stay disciplined you need to keep
grinding you need to keep learning you
to keep doing it otherwise you're just
not going to finish a game right okay
so that being said to sum up what I've
said so far right it starts more make
sure you're making some kind of
small-scale game that you can actually
finish it's a really good idea to make
something small like honestly I'm even
talking about something like a snake or
maybe pac-man or like a game like that
right space invaders whatever make a
game like that first to test out the
toolset that you're using so in other
words you just decided to use unity cool
so make something small so that you can
actually see how you really work see
what it takes to go from start to finish
for a game right if you start some kind
of complicated 3d game and then you kind
of just I don't know you just stop
halfway through or you just spend weeks
working on just the beginning of the
game you don't know how to make a game
right you know how to make like some
kind of level probably that looks kind
of nice graphically that doesn't even
require any programming right like you
you want to do something that you can
complete because then you can say I have
completed game look at my portfolio I've
made this right and I know how to
actually use every aspect of unity I
mean obviously if you're making
something like snake he wouldn't be
using every aspect of unity but what I
mean is you've used the core aspects
that you need such as you've written
scripts you setup entities and game
objects you've actually you've actually
published
you know how exporting works you know
how assets work all that stuff right
okay so start small use an engine okay
there's kind of two two main points that
I've made so far third one programming
right so every game engine requires you
to write some kind of code unreal has
blueprints which is a little bit
different but it is still a form of
programming it's just kind of visual
scripting right visual programming it's
still programming you're still saying do
this if this happens and you're still
kind of going through logic flows and
all that stuff it's just a lot of the
cases into something that's on console
setup now a lot of the cases the logic
is kind of transformed innocent into
some kind of visual added interest into
some kind of node graph that you can
kind of just use to link nodes together
and create some kind of visual script
but all of the mathematical stuff right
like actually doing mathematical
equations it kind of aims to minimize
that in the sense of you want to work
out a collision between two entities or
two game objects or two actors right you
can do that by just by just basically
scripting you know entity 1 dot collides
with entity 2 and if it returns true
you've got a collision right it's
supposed to be really easy that's the
whole point of a game engine is
minimizing that actual low-level
programming that you might have to
experience if you were rocking your own
engine or something like that so with
unity you would probably be using
c-sharp to script you can use JavaScript
or whatever I don't see sharp that's the
way to go because c-sharp is actually a
more useful language for games than
JavaScript would be unless you're making
web games JavaScript really is going to
be more useful web games c-sharp however
I use c-sharp at work all the time
because all of our tools are written in
C sharp so for example the level editor
you know any kind of kind of UI layout
editor editor all of that stuff they're
all written in c-sharp any tools that we
really use so c-sharp is a very useful
language to know that being said unity
c-sharp c-sharp in unity is very
different than c-sharp in the wild or
c-sharp kind of for Microsoft desktop
kind of applications right they're very
very different because because unity
c-sharp is really just using c-sharp as
a scripting language it's got the mono
runtime as well which is a little bit
more limited than Microsoft nap
framework I mean it includes most of it
but there are some things that are
missing so it is a little bit of a
an experience if you're running code for
unit even if you were just using C sharp
by itself but that being said C sharp is
a way better language than JavaScript
way better language than JavaScript so
you're definitely going to want to use
that if using unreal you're going to
have to either use blueprints or C++
I'd recommend blueprints start off with
they're really easy
you'll probably get something up and
running faster again unreal C++ is
filled with custom macros and metadata
and meta programming and stuff like that
that really makes it a lot easier and
also a lot different than kind of
traditional raw I would say C++ and so
that's why there's going to be a
learning curve anyway if you know C++ if
you know c-sharp you're not going to
just be able to pick up unity or unreal
and actually just rock that right it's
going to be different it's there's still
going to be a learning curve you still
need to learn the API and learn how to
actually program in those engines but
the cool thing about those engines is
they come with both tutorials they come
with excellent documentation and API
reference and stuff like that and they
also come with sample projects so you
can actually just boot up a sample
project and just you know check that out
right and then you can see exactly how
they put it together you can see exactly
how they scripted everything if you need
something you can just google it really
there's so many people on forums and
stuff like that that's what I mean like
when you're rocking an engine when
you're using an engine that is popular
and that isn't your own right you're
going to have so many resources out
there that literally you can Google your
way through making a game I'm not even
kidding you could have zero programming
experience and you could Google your way
into mayhem game because really all you
have to do is know how to follow
instructions and probably maybe slightly
tweak or modify a source code that you
end up copying and pasting into your
game and stuff like that but that's kind
of it like that is my tip get a game
engine create some kind of small project
write like have an idea for a small game
that you can actually manage
realistically by yourself including
doing the art for it doing all the
programming for all that stuff pick
something small use a game engine and
then just literally like literally just
Google your way into like how to how to
how to write code for that engine and
how to develop using that engine maybe
watch some video tutorials that you find
on YouTube
you could just bust out some sample
projects again and start kind of looking
inspecting them and reverse engineering
them that's also very common that's
really all there is to it and that's how
you can really get started with making
games right once you've done your first
project you can probably continue on
something maybe a bit more a bit harder
you can probably maybe team up with a
friend and say hey I know how to use
unity or a little a little bit I know
you do as well together we could make
something a bit bigger because like
collaborations really important for game
development people don't make games
alone usually if you look at any kind of
studio I mean they're filled with people
of different disciplines you've got
artists you have designers producers
engineers everyone right development
directors stuff like that right because
it takes a lot to actually make a game
and to manage like older people and yeah
as I said I can keep saying this all day
but making games is really hard so make
sure that you're kind of committed to it
because it's really hard anyway that's
pretty much it let me know what you guys
think of these kind of vlog type me
talking to the camera I just I get a lot
of questions and I never answer them
because the videos I make are just part
of kind of theories so I just I kind of
I like the idea of doing these one-off
videos if you guys have any more
questions that you want me to answer
just drop a comment below or usually
read all comments so that I can see what
you guys want to see and I'm happy to
just literally get out of town head out
into the beauty that is outdoors and
just literally we can just hang out we
just hang out we can just have a talk
and and yeah so anyway you guys enjoy
this video please hit that like button
you can follow me on Twitter and
Instagram as well I'm going to be
posting a lot of the photos that I take
out here on Instagram so make sure you
follow me Darren's
season squeak photos apart from that see
you guys in the next video goodbye
[Music]